that's what I was really proud of I
think I just take your commercial today
about one of our public private
partnerships to produce job
opportunities so I this is a long answer
i'll try to not go too long into it but
so many things we're doing which is just
fundamentally to try to change the
economic reality for residents of the
city of newark and you asked about jobs
but you know everything we've done that
before he gets a jobs from proving and
passing the first city new jersey pass
prevailing wage laws really doing a big
campaign around the Earned Income Tax
Credit just one of the best anti-poverty
programs we have in our country to
create a loan fund for minority
businesses to get access to capital
we've now started to see entrepreneurs
coming forward and availing themselves
and starting businesses in our city but
but just on rote jobs how do you make
sure employments going to happen well
one is we just sat down with our
corporate partners and said look there's
a few corporations in in America that
you're going to talk to and say to them
what are you want of your biggest
challenges and it's all in HR finding
good employees it's orange and then a
quart of America by the way spends
billions of dollars just training the
employees that they get so we sat down
with HR leaders and head of corporations
and said how can we work together and
create a win-win the win for you is
whether we reduce your training costs
get you a better supply of employees
when for us is getting more new workers
hires i'll use continental airlines
which is our biggest employer in the
city but they're only hiring seven
percent of their people from the city of
newark so i went down and talked to a
kellner who was it head of the company
down in houston a phenomenal guy talk to
people here locally we started a
partnership and now we the first year
alone we went from like seven percent to
twenty-five thirty percent of their
hires from the city of newark already
I've been in office you know year nine
months and we've had almost 600 people
hired I filmed the commercial today
because we got now other 600 jobs for
residents of the City of Newark so it's
just incredibly fruitful partnership we
realized that we had these call centers
in the City of Newark we went to these
call centers and said are you hiring our
residents know what's the problem here
and then we took money that was being
wasted before this this job training
money they used to go these job trainers
who would train people give them a
certificate but it wouldn't be connected
jobs or placement rates from work five
percent and so we go to the actual
employers and say let's craft the
program for call center staffers and I
went to speak to the class last week and
they're being hired by all these
different call centers all around the
city and some people who have call
centers outside of the city and we're
getting people hired so it's working and
and now we're starting to see different
companies in newark hire not 10 here 20
here but measuring their hires in the
hundreds as well in addition to that we
always put forth our values it always
starts with what is your ideal excuse me
what is your value and one of our values
very clearly is is hiring local newark
residents another one is hiring
ex-offenders because that's a population
should we not be there for them they're
going to cost us way more green building
as a value so we then look at what our
city incentives like giving away city
land and developers to build giving tax
abatements to incentivize and we link
all of the city ascent incentives to
what our values are you want to tax
abatement in the City of Newark show us
your plan that your project is going to
hire Newark residents kind of higher
ex-offenders going to do green building
and that's the way we've been able to
incentivize a lot more people to hire
locally so we have a whole list of
programs that were working on and then
we partner with nonprofits that further
prepare our residents we prioritize our
nonprofits again the discretionary money
that we have we said these are our
values we're going to give money to
nonprofits that produce jobs when a
non-profit hire ex-offenders we said
what are our values drug treatment was a
value and so on and so forth so we've
got nonprofits that never got support
from the city of newark in the past or
little support like a youth build is a
great program which takes at-risk kids
or not going to college but can get into
the construction trays and actually get
their GED while they actually do the
construction of homes that then be our
affordable homes homes it would sell in
private market for six hundred thousand
dollars and that's going in the private
market for a fraction of that but that
yet they come out of it with a career
you know electrical worker put your kid
with electoral training gets into the
Union to be making 90 thousand dollars
after their apprenticeship so these are
programs that we're targeting and we're
empowering them to succeed and expand
and provide more opportunity for New
York residents and I keep saying
ex-offender reentry over and over again
and that's one of the things we've done
as well
doing a lot of things from going to now
we have about 50 to employers that we've
lined up to that agreed to hire
ex-offenders if we can vet them and
train them and get them soft skills we
had created a legal services
organization that focuses just helping
ex-offenders untangle because most
people go back to prison or violate
parole and what they call technical
parole violations they don't realize
that they have a suspended drivers
license or a parking ticket even worse
that they while they were in prison they
didn't appear for they didn't pay it it
became a warrant out for the arrest and
suspended the driver's license the fines
are all up and here they come out and
all they need is a driver's license to
work for continental but they can't
because the driver's license has 14
thousand dollars with the charges on it
and they don't realize it then the town
over they have a warrant out for their
arrest so we created legal services to
help them untangle all of that reduce
find get rid of warrants and get them
into into employment so we have an array
of a ray of things we do focus on jobs
because again everything is just very
simple in the mission statement in my
pocket right now Newark New Jersey will
set a national standard for urban
transformation three areas Public Safety
economic empowerment and improving the
quality of life for children and
families that's what we're focused on so
the question about jobs is very on point
you